hello everybody a very good morning to
you it is seven o'clock and you are very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on Sky News thousands of ambulance
workers in England and Wales are on
strike for a third time in a dispute
overpay people are being advised only to
call 999 if someone is seriously injured
or their life is in danger and
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi is fighting to save his job this
morning Sky News has learned that he
settled a seven-figure bill with hmrc
while he was serving as Chancellor in a
few minutes we'll speak to the
independent tax expert whose
investigation could have cost him
Millions it's Monday the 23rd of January
today's strike will involve thousands of
paramedics control room staff and
support workers who are walking out
overpay
pay us more we are live on the picket
line as paramedics across the Northwest
start two days of strike action
as much of the country Shivers under a
blanket of freezing fog the National
Grid implements an emergency plan to pay
more than a million customers to use
less energy and help prevent blackouts
senior conservatives say Nadeem zahawi
must give more information about his tax
bill whether he paid a penalty to hmrc
and questions to Boris Johnson II Labor
reporting to the commons Watchdogs over
an 800 000 pound loan allegedly secured
with the help of the now BBC chairman
also ahead a man's suspected of killing
10 people in a Chinese New Year mass
shooting in California is fronted
Belinda says it won't stop Poland from
sending german-made leopard tanks to
Ukraine
also ahead we'll speak to England rugby
Legend Lawrence delalio about how he's
getting disadvantaged kids involved in
the game and using it to turn their
lives around and
[Music]
rocking royalty Ed Sheeran and Elton
John are among the stars who could be
asked to perform in a special coronation
concert at Windsor Castle
[Music]
good morning everyone thousands of
paramedics call handling staff and
support workers are on strike today and
people are being urged only to call 999
in a life-threatening emergency the
health secretary Steve Barclay has
described the walkout as hugely
disappointing union leaders accused
ministers are failing to make any
sincere effort to end the dispute
overpay
these are the areas affected by the
strike they include Unison stuff in
London Yorkshire the North West
Northeast and also the South West unite
workers in the West Midlands Northwest
Northeast East Midlands and Wales
and GMB union workers in the West
Midlands Instagram Rashid is joining us
now from a picket line outside north
west Ambulance Service in Chorley in
Lancashire
um hi Izzy good morning I'm sure it's
this freezing cold up there as it is
down here in the Southeast this morning
what are the Striking workers saying to
you good morning
we've got ambulance coming in the
background I think they say made of
tougher stuff up here okay and clearly
that's something that many people will
need over the next couple of days as
Northwest Ambulance Service many of
their members will strike over the next
couple of days this morning a few people
out already as you can see more expected
to turn up and we'll see how much
support that they get from the public of
course up to around 15
000 Unison ambulance workers will strive
for the third time in five weeks and
they'll be joined by 5 000 of their NHS
colleagues at two Hospital trusts in
Liverpool so the North West will be hit
in terms of services when it comes to
ambulance services and Hospital work as
well let's bring in a paramedic Gary
Blackburn who can actually just give us
a sense of why this is happening why is
this so important for you Gary why is it
that you're out here early morning
striking so I've been a paramedic for 30
years I'm a representative for unite
also the health service has over a
hundred thousand vacancies and we can't
retain our staff the latest pay award
for some staff is as low as 2.2 percent
with inflation being around 10 percent
is eight percent below inflation and
staff cannot afford to live like that if
we can't retain the staff we can't
deliver the service that we need to
deliver and the public our neighbors
friends relatives deserve the better
service than we can deliver so that is
the bottom line it is more money you are
asking for more money they currently the
government say there is not enough in
the pot to service you we need we need
to save the NHS and in order to save the
NHS we need to retain the staff that we
have in the NHS and at the moment we're
not able to do that which means we can't
deliver the service that you my
relatives your neighbors deserve we know
we're not delivering that service at the
moment so we need to change something to
make sure that we can can I ask a bit
about the disruption you know there will
be people watching this today in the
Northwest in particular and thinking you
know I I couldn't even you know get an
ambulance to come to me quick enough
before now there's loads going on strike
it's going to be even more difficult is
that not a concern for you that people
will be looking at the TV and going hang
on a minute you know when when can I get
an ambulance to me of course that is a
concern and that United have worked
extremely hard with North Northwest
Ambulance Service and United have worked
with other ambulance trust to ensure
that we've got derogations in place so
we've had many many meetings we've got
agreements for what category of patient
will receive an ambulance we've got a
commitment that if there is a serious
case that members of the ambulance
service on this picket line will leave
to go straight to that job so we we do
our very best to make sure that the
public are not in danger Gary in a quick
answer are you confident you can get a
resolution soon I'm confident we have to
save the NHS yes that wasn't a yes or no
to getting a resolution interesting
let's get a response from Steve Barkley
this is what he said over the weekend it
is hugely disappointing some ambulance
workers are continuing to take
industrial action I've had constructive
talks with unions about this coming
Year's pay process for
2023-2024 and I'm Keen to continue
talking about what is Affordable and
fair but clearly regardless of any
discussions of how close they're getting
it's quite clear from these members and
Northwest Ambulance Service that over
the next couple of days they will
continue with their strikes and there is
no doubt Kay that there will be
disruption ahead for many
okay but no thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
well if you want to be part of a special
debate on the future of the NHS this
week simply scan this QR code there you
are which will bring up an email form
for you to apply to be part of the
audience at University Hospital Coventry
We'll be asking can the NHS survive you
can also email NHS crisis at sky.uk
directly that's uh this Thursday 7 P.M
on Sky News you want to be part of the
audience you've got a question let us
know
and at 2PM just a few hours before that
Sarah Jean Sarah J and me will be
hosting a phone in NHS your say we want
to hear your experiences good or bad
whether it's getting an appointment with
your GP waiting for an ambulance or
surgery or visiting a e call us now
020-8167-220-81672200 and leave us a
message to book your slot
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi is fighting to save his job this
morning uh Sky News has learned that he
settled a seven-figure bill with hmrc
while he was serving as Chancellor
senior conservatives are calling for Mr
zahawi to give more information about
his tax bill and whether he paid a
penalty to hmrc labors accused him of
spending a week dodging questions
the party chair annalize Dodd said this
whole episode is deeply damaging to
public trust with a Chancellor in charge
of the nation's finances asking the
public to pay their taxes while
apparently having failed to do so
himself his position is clearly
unturnable every hour that Rishi sunak
refuses to sack him shows just how weak
the prime minister is
well in a few moments we'll be speaking
to the tax expert Dan needle who
investigated Mr zahawi's Tax Affairs and
find out what he's got to say that story
gets a lot of coverage in the papers
this morning the Daily Mirror pictures
Nadeem zahawi which is Mr Johnson with
the headline they still don't get it
the Metro leads to the questions
surrounding the BBC chair Richard
Sharp's alleged involvement in Boris
Johnson's personal finances before Mr
Johnson recommended him for the role
both men deny any wrongdoing
while the Delhi Express focuses on Boris
Johnson making a surprise visit to
Ukraine the eye says energy companies
will respond to the government
considering a ban on the forcible
installation of prepayment meters in
people's homes by increasing prices
the telegraph says the National Grid is
getting ready to pay people to use less
energy as the country faces days of cold
weather
so more than a million house cells are
going to be paid to use less electricity
today as part of an emergency plan to
prevent power Cuts during the cold
weather what's all this about are we
close to blackouts Matthew has more for
us what's the plan Matthew
well as you say okay for the very first
time the National Grid is going to
implement an emergency scheme to try and
save as much energy as possible and
prevent the lights going out it's
because the UK is facing as you may know
if you look outside your window an
extraordinary freeze at the moment
certainly London woke up to a blanket of
freezing fog this morning there's a
light dusting of frost here on
Westminster bridge and that's going to
create a spike in demand for energy wind
power is generating less than it usually
does at this time of year so there are
some concerns that there will be a
shortage of Supply the National Grid
therefore activates something called the
demand flexibility service which will
essentially pay around a million energy
customers in the country only those who
have Smart Meters only those who are
subscribed to the 26 or so energy
companies who've signed up to this
scheme but they will be paid essentially
to use less energy than they otherwise
would it's happening between five and
six pm this evening it's not asking
people to sit in the dark or sit in the
cold it's more a question of using
appliances particularly energy intensive
appliances differently so you might cook
your dinner in the oven slightly later
you might put the washing on at a
slightly different time and these
million or so customers will be paid
between three and six pounds per unit of
energy that they don't use that they
otherwise might have used and the
National Grid has tested this on at
least two occasions they say it shows
their testing shows that it does
actually reduce consumer demand for
energy so this is why they're bringing
it in today they've also as a
precautionary measure asked two
coal-fired power units at Drax station
in North Yorkshire and another one in
Nottinghamshire to warm up and be ready
to generate electricity just in case but
a spokesperson for the National Grid and
indeed the government this morning both
stressing people shouldn't be worried
this is not necessarily a question of
the lights going out it's more in the
words of the National Grid spokesman a
precautionary measure to ensure that
there's sufficient spare City in the
system so it's not a question
necessarily they say of rolling
blackouts it's more a question of taking
precautions and making sure that there
is enough energy to go around Matthew a
lot of people watching this morning will
be thinking I need to make the kids tea
at that time
um tonight how can I possibly not be
using energy
well it's a question of perhaps using
energy slightly more efficiently so you
might for example I suppose put your tea
in the microwave as opposed to the oven
because the oven uses more energy or it
might be a question of delaying it
slightly or as I say not putting your
washing on between five and six or or
doing whatever you can to to adjust your
usage of energy not everyone has to do
it it's not a requirement it's just you
can do so in the knowledge that if you
do use less energy between those key
hours of five and six pm you will be
compensated for it again if you're one
of those million customers who has a
smart meter and is one of the 26 energy
companies have signed up to this scheme
and as I say you'll be paid somewhere
between three and six pounds per unit of
energy that you don't use so you can
choose to Avail yourself of that option
if you wish but if you've got to get the
kids dinner on then no one's saying that
you can't do that this evening okay
thank you foreign
and that's what's putting pressure on
the National Grid we will be speaking to
the National Grid at 9 20 this morning
at meantime Steph standing by for us uh
it was freezing this morning coming in
it's going to get even colder
it is bitterly cold in fact Heathrow was
showing minus eight degrees that is
super cold and as well as that we're
also now seeing some fog this is
actually the time we're most likely to
see the fog appear you can see behind me
rather a pretty sunrise and that sun
just injects that little bit more
movement in the air and also starts to
melt some of the ice and that injection
of moisture is what triggers a fair
amount of fog to foam at this time
specifically so it might not have been
foggy where you are about half an hour
ago but it might be now so don't count
your chickens before you check out the
window as well as seeing a fair amount
of fog also for the same reasons that
we're seeing the fog we're also seeing a
fair amount of air pollution as well so
we've got very light winds we've also
got the atmosphere is sort of trapping
all the pollutants by the ground so we
are seeing a fair amount of air
pollution particularly by roads at the
moment but let's have a look at the full
forecast and see what's going to happen
with the weather over the next few days
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
hello there well we've got lots of
sunshine down in southern parts of
England and also the southern parts of
Wales and further north there's more in
the way of cloud and it's rather murky
but for many parts of Scotland Ireland
and Northern Ireland that's where we've
already got the mild air so at the
moment the temperatures are above
freezing by a long way seven or eight
degrees but down in the Southeast we're
below freezing some places minus seven
or eight it's the brighter weather in
the South that'll hold out during the
day today but stay bitterly cold in the
north staying mild but with some showers
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
man suspected of killing 10 people in a
mass shooting at a Chinese New Year's
celebration in California has been found
dead in the driver's seat of a van
please name the suspect a 72 year old
who can Tran and said he'd shot and
killed himself as officers closed on in
on him our U.S grossful at Martha
Kellner reports
a suspect surrounded 30 miles from the
ballroom dancehall where the massacre
happened inside the white van was this
man 72 year old who can Tran alleged to
have shot dead 10 people and injured
scores more
his body found slumped in the driver's
seat but troubling questions remain
what was the motive for this shooter
did he have a mental illness
was he a domestic violence abuser
how did he get these guns and was it
through legal means or not
it had been a Saturday of Celebration
here this was the eve of Chinese New
Year in a predominantly Asian American
city
the after night fell as a ballroom dance
class took place the gunman opened fire
he then went to another dance venue in
the nearby city of Alhambra The Killing
Spree would probably have continued but
he was disarmed by two people
this quiet community rocked by violence
it was it it really is really sad
I was looking forward to be here
celebrating but
even if I'm not celebrating I'm part
with them so I wanted to be here and
like
tell the Asian community that they're
very special to me he is the deadliest
shooting in California in recent memory
this was supposed to be day two of the
Chinese New Year celebrations but
they're taking down the signs and
dismantling the Stalls because Monterey
Park is now the focus of America's gun
violence epidemic
another mass shooting means another
chorus of calls for gun control
legislation it's difficult for a lot of
people to understand yes an individual
can get hold of such a powerful weapon
that can kill 10 people yes of course
you know thank you bro they only have
one 30 round magazine put on the rep and
they can kill many people gun is a
danger gun only for the people
professional like law enforcement or
they need that but not why you need the
gun this land needs your father local
people gathered to pray the immediate
danger may have passed here but gun
violence is the never-ending scourge of
life in this country
Martha Kellner Sky News Monterey Park
also coming up on the program for you
this morning convicted sex offender
Elaine Maxwell has claimed a photograph
showing prince Andrew with his arm
around the then 17 year old Virginia
Frey is fake speaking in a video
interview from inside prison Maxwell
claimed there is no photograph adding
that she'd only ever seen a photocopy of
it Mr Freya used the picture to support
her allegations against the prince in a
case that was settled outside of Court
Ms Maxwell had previously said that the
photograph was genuine
hundreds of mourners have attended a
memorial for Lisa Marie Presley at
Graceland in Tennessee following her
death 11 days ago her mother Priscilla
paid an emotional tribute saying our
heart is broken as she read a poem by
her granddaughter
Demar Hamlin received a standing ovation
from fans when he appeared on the big
screens at the Buffalo Bills and
Cincinnati Bengals NFL game the American
football star was attending the game
less than three weeks after he suffered
a cardiac arrest while playing for the
bills
still to come on the program for you
with thousands of ambulance ambulance
workers staging a fresh day of strike
speaking to the boss of the unite Union
that's Sharon Graham
Labor's Shadow business secretary
Jonathan Reynolds will be with me soon
after eight o'clock and with the SNP
calling on the PM to sat Nadim zahawi
over his tax Affairs speak to the
party's leader in Westminster that's
Stephen Flynn
a toy party chair facing further
questions over his financial affairs
after his emergency settled a dispute
with tax authorities while he was
Chancellor on Saturday Nadim zahawi said
that he'd pay the hmrc as some link to
what he called a careless error joined I
by the labor supporting tax expert Dan
needle who investigated Mr zahawi's
Affairs hello to you thanks for joining
us on the program this morning
on the labor supporting thing I advise
politicians of all four main parties and
I've annoyed politicians of all four
main parties our work is non-partisan
and most people respect that but what
about you do you support the labor party
you're not a labor party member
personally I support the local party but
I keep my tax analysis and my legal work
separate from my private political views
always have them okay why did Nadeem
zahawi's tax refers first come to your
attention
so back in July there was a report in
some of the press that the NCAA the SFO
and hmrc had investigated his tax and he
denied it but then you wouldn't
necessarily know if you're being
investigated so I started looking and I
saw something very odd in the way that
his original Founders shares in newgov
were structured
and from that I concluded it looked like
he had not paid about 3.7 million in tax
he
threatened to sue me and other
newspapers looking at it and the whole
thing went really rather quiet until it
was revealed to just um a week and a day
ago that at the same time he was denying
it and sending threatening letters to
people
he'd actually fessed up to hmrc that he
did own the tax and he paid it plus
penalties
um when Mr zahawi uh spoke to me on the
11th of July last year when he was
hoping to be the next prime minister
um during the leadership battle for
number 10. he said neither he nor his
wife had benefited benefited from any
offshore funds
why did you why do you sorry why do you
say that he has
so I saw that and my jaw dropped because
there was clear evidence in a Hugo of
disclosure from 2005 that we just have
it by by some corporate Quirk we see
this that he benefited because he
received 99
000 pounds from vulture Investments held
by the trust that's not my supposition
or a guess absolute fact and yet he
denied that to you
I I said to his lawyers why is he saying
this to Kay Burley when the evidence
says it's not true
and they wouldn't reply
how much do you calculate go on sorry
come on right so start with 99 000. if
you receive 99 000 and we just
discovered it by luck it's fair to infer
there have been other payments and now
if he was as report suggest actually
taxed and paid 3.7 million I'm guessing
on about 27 million of incoming gains he
didn't declare then that suggests he
received a lot of money millions of
pounds from the trust and he told you he
didn't benefit at all
do we do we know for a fact though that
he has received more than the 99 000
pounds which you say there is a paper
trail for do we do we know that he's
received we don't know how he received
it but if he was taxed 3.7 million
pounds plus penalties and didn't receive
any money and that's a huge Injustice
and I'm behind him 100 I'm guessing he
would have said so
you don't you're not generally taxed on
money that you don't get
how much do you calculate that he has
because we don't know how much do you
calculate that he has paid to hmrc
um well we don't know but the leaks
suggested a figure of 3.7 million plus
interest and penalties and that is so
close to the figure that I estimated
that it makes me think that my original
supposition back in July was correct
so how much money do you think he's
received
I I think he will have received about 27
million pounds and not paid tax on it
until eventually he was forced to
because it was being reported didn't
admit it denied it threatened to sue
people and went to hmrc to quietly
settle it
he said that hmrc has accepted that he
made a mistake and his error was
careless and not deliberate why is that
not the end of the matter
well to say it's not deliberate as if
it's a triumphant result it is a bit is
a bit funny if it was deliberate he'd be
arrested for criminal tax evasion
careless means something specific
careless means that you didn't behave in
a reasonable way a reasonable way is you
instruct decent tax advisors you tell
them the truth you follow their advice
you check your final tax returns best
you can if you do those things then even
if it turns out the tax was wrong even
if your tax advisors were total clowns
you're not careless so if you're
careless it often means you didn't get
advice at all in his case that would
mean he could have received the money 27
million pounds perhaps not taken advice
and not paid tax if that is what
happened
that's a huge deal
um how will we find out
well we have no way to find out because
hmrc quite rightly have a duty of
confidentiality however if Mr zahari
thinks he needs to continue to be a
senior politician he owes us an honest
answer he needs to explain exactly what
happened explain exactly why he didn't
pay the tax and most importantly explain
why he told me
told you in that interview
told pretty much everyone that his tax
Affairs were hunky-dory at the same time
that he knew they weren't
are you suggesting that he intentionally
avoided tax
now if he'd attentionally avoided tax
then that would be criminal tax evasion
and he would have been dishonest I can't
read his mind he says and I had no
reason to disbelieve him hmrc concluded
that he was careless not deliberate but
I am suggesting he deliberately didn't
tell me and you and everyone else that
there was a problem with his tax Affairs
when he knew there was and I'm also
suggesting that he told you he had no
interest in the trust when he must have
done
um
a non-deliberate error not set up an
offshore structure to avoid tax is what
the hmrc has accepted he hasn't broken
the law he has paid any outstanding
monies with a 30 penalty or thereabouts
um I suppose a lot of people watching
this morning would say surely you know
he's put his hands up he made a mistake
he's paid the money he needed to that's
it
well we we all make mistakes we are lost
a pen yesterday I had no idea where it
was
um I thought I felt ridiculous I was
using it a mistake where you don't
declare 27 million pounds
if we accept everything he says and that
wasn't intentional
that that's an amazing mistake to make
and you've got a question whether
someone who makes that mistake is
suitable for public life for me though
that's less important than the quite
deliberate fact that he when he knew
there was something wrong with his tax
affairs
sent lawyers after me and others trying
to report on it and told you that he had
no interest in a trust which he surely
did and then say we should come to the
bit that you mentioned earlier that I I
haven't picked up best of all worst of
all
he went to hmrc to negotiate a
settlement
when he was Chancellor of the exchequer
so what do you want to happen
it could be there's an innocent
explanation for this which makes perfect
sense I lap the imagination to see it
and if there isn't one I think it should
resign
I noticed um a tweet that you you I
think it was yesterday
um you say um that Mr sahawi's lawyers
have written to you denying that hmrc
investigated him under cop nine the
procedure for investigating
fraud
um
just explain that to me
well I was interested in his in his
statement he said they concluded it
wasn't deliberate it was a mistake which
suggested perhaps they thought at one
point it was deliberate so I asked him
do what did it start out as a fraud
investigation and he said no
okay
um I've I've seen a note from Mr
zahawi's lawyers um responding to you
saying that Mr Tsar was not being
investigated for fraud so his tax
repayment was not being blown out of
proportion since it's not being
considered currently
um as anything criminal is that
reasonable to say
if everything he says is true then then
yes it wasn't Criminal it was it was a
careless mistake but I think we want
higher standards from our politicians
than not being criminal don't we we seem
to be at some of a standoff though don't
we because you you want him to
come clean and basically to resign
because you feel that when he was
Chancellor you can't have any uh
investigation by hmrc even though you
said that he probably didn't know uh
initially that he's his tax Affairs were
being investigated while your Chancellor
so
um what would be okay how do you how do
you feel okay that he you asked him a
direct question and he gave you an
answer which is absolutely false when it
comes to the 99 000 pound and he knew
that and which is almost certainly false
given he's paying the tax how have you
had a politician give you an answer
which which we know was false has that
happened before
many many many times I'm crashingly died
I was sure many times but you know
you're telling me that he was being
economical with the actuality when he
was speaking uh to me you say that
you've got this figure of 99 000 pounds
and you can then leap and surmise that
potentially uh he benefited in the form
of 27 million friends but what I'm
saying is if you find the 99 000 why why
can you not find the rest oh the only
way we find the 99
000 is there was accidentally an
unlawful loan made to the directors it's
a mistake it happens all the time and
that was repaid via a gift and because
it had been an unlawful loan the way it
was repaid is disclosed until 2005
documents it's a complete fluke we we
can find that out normally we'd have no
way to see the gifts
what you want him to resign because you
feel that he hasn't behaved
appropriately while in public office he
threatened to sue me for reporting on
something which he denied and turns out
to be true I I don't think politicians
should do that
uh what's going to happen next
well I expect people will keep asking
him to come clean and he will either
come clean and provide a satisfactory
explanation and I will eat to my
collection of hats or he won't come
clean and will have to resign
and the 99
000 pounds which is the only figures
that you can find at the moment we don't
even know how much he's paid to hmrc or
if indeed he has but he says that he's
paid some we don't know if that includes
a fine or or not oh we do because he
admits being careless which absolutely
means there was a penalty the the word
careless has a particular tax meaning
okay okay I didn't understand that thank
you for explaining that
um you will continue on with this though
will you until you try to uncover more
funds or have to eat those hats
I will this I prefer doing nerdy tax
policy that hardly anyone reads but I'm
not going to let this drop
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
program thank you thank you very much
bye thank you bye
pay money takes your choice with many of
you waking up to Sub-Zero temperatures
this morning let's look at some of the
best pictures from around the UK this
was kilchen Castle on the banks of the
partially frozen lock or Argyle and
Butte a few miles north and this was the
scene of snow covered peaks in Glencoe
in London's Bushy Park
um
Paris swans were pictured flying over a
frozen pond next to me like they were
trying to land and then thought more of
it and one of them landed for a closer
inspection there you go you see and it
was frozen underfoot for walkers on the
grounds of the Sandringham estate in
Norfolk if you want to send us any of
your curl weather pictures you can do so
on Twitter at Cape early
still to come on the program before you
former commander of the Joint Forces
command generals Sir Richard Barons
joins us on the program not to come
foreign
everybody welcome back to the breakfast
show here on Sky News pressure mounting
on the Tory party chairman Nadeem zahawi
after it emerged he settled to dispute
with the tax authorities while he was
Chancellor a short while ago I spoke to
tax expert Dan needle who investigated
the conservative party chairman of
financial affairs he gave an estimate of
how much he believes Mr zahari received
without initially paying tax and told me
the former Chancellor's description of
what happened as careless not deliberate
is telling
I think he will have received about 27
million pounds and not paid tax on it
until eventually he was forced to
because it was being reported didn't
admit it denied it threatened to see
people and went to hmrc to quietly
settle it
he said that hmrc has accepted that he
made a mistake and his error was
careless and not deliberate why is that
not the end of the matter
well to say it's not deliberate as if
it's a triumphant result is a bit is a
bit funny if it was deliberate he'd be
arrested for criminal tax evasion
careless means something specific
careless means that you didn't behave in
a reasonable way a reasonable way is you
instruct decent tax advisors
you tell them the truth you follow their
advice you check your final tax returns
best you can if you do those things then
even if it turns out the tax was wrong
even if your tax advisors were total
clowns you're not careless so if you're
careless it often means you didn't get
advice at all in his case that would
mean he could have received the money
for 87 million pounds perhaps not taken
advice and not paid tax if that is what
happened
that's a huge deal
Amanda good morning good morning where
do we go from the here well I think it's
very clear from that interview with Dan
needle there how many huge unanswered
questions there still are around Nadine
zahawi's tax Affairs what exactly
um happened why the explanations that
were given were given uh the amount of
the settlement
um the amount of the penalty for him to
save his job
I mean I think he needs to as Ian Duncan
Smith indeed yesterday was saying he
needs to come clean and set everything
out in the open because I think at the
moment it is still very murky and
unclear and I think the real question
this morning is so Rishi sunak is he
going to stand by the chair of the party
or is he going to force him to resign
Labor's Angel Arena has just tweeted
um every hour Rishi sunak refuses to
sack him shows how weak he is and I
think that really will sting now of
course as we've heard then Nadine zahawi
says he was careless that it wasn't a
deliberate decision not to pay these
really huge sums of tax that ended up
being owed while he was the chancellor
but this is really bad optics for Rishi
sunak he's a prime minister that came to
power really not very long ago promising
to clear up politics to to run a
government of professionalism
accountability and integrity and of
course any questions around offshore
trusts and payments of tax remind
everyone about the issues he had with
his wife's own non-dom status it's
already a big attack line for labor I
think many in the party will be
wondering whether it's really worth it
to continue this ongoing discussion this
focus on Nadim zahawi's tax Affairs at a
time when they want to be talking about
the NHS trying to get onto the front
foot after what was a very difficult
week last week which ended up with the
Prime Minister being fined for not
wearing a seat belt and particularly at
a time where they're also made in
another Scandal over the weekend this
time about his predecessor Boris Johnson
and about a loan guarantee that was
agreed that was reportedly helped
arranged by a man called Richard Sharp
who a few weeks later went on to become
chair of the BBC on Boris Johnson's
recommendation now he's denied it's a
conflict of interest Boris Johnson's
spokesperson has said it's all rubbish
the cabinet office say the correct
process was followed
um but and of course this did happen
before unit became prime minister but
this all of this adds to a sense of a
sort of miasma of sneeze around this
government particularly as Mr Sharp
himself was uh Rishi soon as boss before
when he worked at Goldman Sachs as well
and I think for the public out there
struggling with the cost of living
crisis this sense of a government which
is above above the rules and not playing
by them is is really going to hurt okay
Amanda for no thanks very much induce or
Boris Johnson there in Ukraine over the
weekend surprise visit
um actually we can tell you the city of
Bak much in the east of the country has
been the focus of intense fighting for
many months Ukrainian troops have been
holding off determined Russian advances
but suspect that Moscow is now preparing
for a huge offensive in a moment we'll
speak to former British Army Commander
generals Sir Richard Barons but first
our International correspondent Alex
Rossi has spent time with soldiers
defending the city and sent this special
report
foreign
down Russia's Advance on back moot is
choking The Roots into the city at the
epicenter of this war
we traveled on one of the remaining
roads in
it is a sketchy nervous Journey along
smashed up streets
everywhere here is in the line of fire
and the casualties on both sides have
been staggering
it's clear this grueling fight is
morphing into urban combats
inside the city Ukrainian forces are
making fortifications
lines of Soviet era tanks and armored
vehicles are concealed amongst the
buildings
this city has become a symbolic prize
for Russia
although it appears to be of small
strategic value
it's pretty much deserted around here at
the moment there are a few civilians
over there a man collecting wood but
most of these apartment blocks have been
damaged by shelling and people have left
the city it's very unnerving
just being here but the fighting now is
very very close
there are still a few remaining people
who are trying to salvage their
belongings
those remaining are terrified but don't
know where else to go
foreign
[Music]
Ukrainian soldiers told us Russian
forces are now on the edge of the city
and they say they desperately need more
modern weapons if that has stopped
Vladimir Putin's Army in its tracks
we need weapons today because after
tomorrow this city can be destroyed
already and if we will be wait I can die
but I want to live and I want to support
my country if you wait
maybe Russian will be in Poland tomorrow
we can wait one month one year I don't
know how many time but if we can't stop
rushing now uh your army must stop
Russian tomorrow
[Music]
is preparing for another massive Russian
offensive the soldiers here hope they
can resist but after the loss of the
nearby town of solidar they expect
another Relentless fight Alex Rossi Sky
News back moot
I'm joining us now is former commander
of the Joint Forces command that's
General Sir Richard Barons hello to you
um Sir Richard thanks for joining us on
the program
um this morning why weren't the Germans
um allow leopard two tanks to be
licensed for uh use in Ukraine
well it's obviously been a very
difficult conversation in Germany partly
historical Legacy and and partly I think
because of German's trade and energy
Reliance on on on Russia but the the
effect of the delay in Germany of
agreeing to send their own tanks and
letting other people who have bought
German tanks send theirs means that they
are now handicapping the Ukrainian
prospects for stopping the Russian
offensive they know there's coming and
mounting their own in 2023. although
they could I suppose uh look further
west and point out that the US is not
sending their Abram tanks
um yes they could there are some genuine
military logistic reasons for not
sending Abrams it's a it's a very
complex machine it's quite hard to
maintain and it generally runs off
aviation fuel not diesel so it would
mean Ukraine having a very complex
supply line and the Americans have set
that up we should remember the the US
have sent more than 50 billion dollars
worth of Military Support so they are
well in well ahead of anybody else in
supporting Ukraine
it excuse me is it not something to do
with um a close Ally of Putin
um warning that deliveries of Western
weapons including tanks to Ukraine will
lead to a global catastrophe
so the Russians have have
oh
I think we may have um just lost you
there Sir Richard I don't think you're
on mute are you
nope nope
okay we seem to have a problem
um hearing you just at the moment Sir
Richard I'm so sorry about this we'll
sort that out and come back to you
momentarily I do beg your pardon
um my apologies not sure what's going on
there
um those Gremlins first thing Monday
morning I'm going to blame it on the
cold
um coming up in just a few moments time
we're going to be talking in more detail
about the ambulance strike it was minus
six this morning when I came into work
and ambulance workers are on strike in
those freezing conditions this morning
we heard from uh insi who was up on um a
picket line in the Northwest in surely
in Lancashire this morning another
series of considerable strikes for the
ambulance unions and we'll be speaking
to their leader in just a few moments
time
uh meantime some of today's other
headlines for you energy bills could be
hundreds of pounds lower than previously
thought in the second half of this year
analysis by Cornwall Insight found that
the average household's Energy bill
could be 2 200 pounds a year from July
that's around 300 pounds less than
predicted
ambulances with dimmable lights and
specially trained paramedics will form
part of 150 million pound investment in
Mental Health Services the government
has set out plans for 150 new specialist
facilities and up to 100 New specialist
mental health ambulances to be put into
service over the next two years
the head of the CBI will today say that
the UK is lagging behind on growth in a
speech at University College London Tony
danker is expected to call on Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt to take big decisions to
boost the economy he'll urge the
government to reform the consent process
for green infrastructure and news
regulation to stimulate domestic demand
for green technologies
as I was saying thousands of ambulance
workers in England and Wales the staging
a fresh day of strikes today in their
ongoing dispute over pay and Staffing
they want double-digit wage increases to
help keep up with inflation but the
government says that is unaffordable
joined Now by The General Secretary of
the United Union Sharon Graham hi Ms
Graham it's good to see you this morning
thanks for joining us um your members on
the picket lines again this morning how
are they feeling
well okay they're feeling very very
disappointed it's been five weeks since
unite ambulance workers were out on
strike and we believed what the
government said that they were serious
about resolution and in that five weeks
there has been absolutely no offer being
put on the table uh Rishi sunak is
missing in action it's very very clear
that he now needs to come to the table
as the CEO of UK PLC come to the table
and deal with this dispute
last week I think it was last Friday you
said the government is demonizing your
words ambulance workers about life and
limb cover what were you referring to
there
well um unfortunately ministers and I'm
going to use the word lie ministers have
lied continuously about ambulance
workers not doing life and limb cover
that is totally and utterly untrue I was
on the picket line in the West Midlands
and there was life in them covered
people were coming off the picket line
to give extra support in relation to
that and there's something where
ministers are beginning to lie in the
middle of a dispute and so therefore
what I want them to do and I want Rishi
sunak now to come to the table it's very
clear Kay that Stephen Barkley does not
have any Authority he doesn't have the
authority to do the deal there hasn't
even been one single offer in five weeks
so we now need Rishi sunat to take this
seriously this is the NHS get round the
table let's do the deal and let these
people go back to work
has there been any communication with
the Prime Minister either by you or
other representatives of the NHS unions
prime minister has absolutely not spoken
to us about this in any way shape or
form to be honest with you I haven't
seen him uh very often in the last five
weeks anywhere apart from in the back of
a car not wearing seatbelt and what he
needs to do now is he needs to come to
the table and do the deal that we need
to do to get these people back to work
this is his responsibility this is the
biggest abdication of leadership that I
have seen in negotiations ever in 30
years of negotiating he needs to do the
job he's paid for get round the table so
these people now can get back to work
you've called for the abolition of the
NHS pay review body I believe the
government would say that's an
independent peer review body that helps
decide how much money is available uh
for the the round of pay for NHS workers
um why do you want it abolished
okay with this and I think it's probably
um
now I said it isn't independent that is
really part of the problem but also the
scoping around it the government really
gives it such a steer that it can't
really come out of that straight jacket
and the government picks and chews since
in 2014 it didn't accept the pay review
bodies recommendations in 2018 we're
negotiating with the government on
salaries fines so it really is picking
and choosing how it uses it what we
should do is what happens every other
negotiation I'm the leader of the
biggest private sector Union the private
sector wouldn't operate like this if
there's negotiations of this of this
caliber the CEO would be in a room with
me would be negotiating and would put a
deal back to the members that's what the
government needs to do now either Rishi
sunak is not up to the job and he
doesn't know how to negotiate or there
is something more Sinister going on here
so I'm calling him to come to the table
sit down with the general secretaries
let's get a deal on the table and then
we can give that deal back to our
members to vote on
I think it's fair to say that it's
becoming very clear that the government
is unlikely to budge on a pay deal this
year you're only um two or three months
away from next year's negotiations by
that I mean um April 2023 is now the
time to put a pin in this and start
negotiating better deal for next year
well that would mean that these workers
didn't get a pay rise for 22 and 23 and
to be honest with you we cannot allow
that to happen you know it sounds like
white noise but these were the people
that were put out there in the pandemic
when we didn't have a vaccine nobody
knew what was going to go on people were
dying NHS workers died and I think it's
a National Disgrace an absolute National
Disgrace that we are not giving these
these workers a proper pay rise so we
are going to be here until the
government comes to its senses and
decides to talk about 22 and 23. they
need to come back to the negotiating
table and put an offer in they've been
around your studio okay saying they're
in constructive talks and they are
talking about offers we've had no offer
and unfortunately I can't put the words
constructive talks in the ballot paper I
need to have a deal that I can put back
to the members so that they can then
ballot and everybody can go back to work
what what does um increased
um industrial action look like though
because obviously what you're doing at
the moment is not making the government
budge at all what what more can you do
well I suppose the 6th of February is
um you know quite a sad day for the NHS
this is obviously a day when you're
going to have paramedics NHS workers
across the piece nurses all coming out
together which is the first time that
that's happened we've tried to sort of
make the strikes happen when we don't
come out all at the same time so that
that's better for the service now what I
would hope is that the government at the
very least if they're not listening to
the NHS workers at the very least listen
to the public the surveys are clearly
showing that the public who by the way
are their voters want them to sort this
out and they agree that they should get
a pay rise so if Rishi sunak decides to
ignore the public then I think that will
cost him badly at The Ballot Box what
they need to do now is to listen to the
public listen to the workforce come
around the table do a negotiation that
we can put back to our members we are
compromising they can hear that in terms
of what we're saying come to the table
and let's see if we can get a deal
if lives are lost on the 6th of February
when ambulance workers emergency call
handlers and nurses all come out on
strike on the same day who will be
responsible for that
well look the first thing I'd say well
the government fairly and squarely but
the first thing I would say is I really
hope the 6th of February does not happen
there's a lot of days between now and
the 6th of February the government has
an opportunity anytime they want to
bring the general secretaries in a room
we will all be there at a drop of the
Hat we'll cancel and we'll clear all
Diaries to do it but even on the 6th of
February we are going to make sure that
we have life and new cover but I would
say this cake is it's an important
figure 500 people
500 people are dying every single week
waiting for an ambulance in the fifth
richest economy in the world that is an
absolute National Disgrace
it's not helping though is it when your
members go out on strike
but I suppose what um what we would say
to that case what else we've got to do
we're trying to talk to them we're
trying to bring them around a table
we're trying to say come and negotiate
which if we're doing everything we can
to get them to come to the table and
they're absolutely refusing but I have
to say this is about pay of course it is
absolutely about pay but it's also about
the very existence of the NHS how could
we have a situation on a normal day when
no strike is taking place whatsoever
that 500 people are dying in Britain
every week waiting for an ambulance that
is unbelievable that that is happening
in our country so we have to put a stake
in the ground we have to defend the NHS
and the public wants us to do that also
okay we must leave it there um thank you
for taking the time to join us this
morning do keep us in touch with any
movement on these continuing strikes
thanks a lot
thank you
uh well coming up we're going to be
talking about that in more detail with
the Labor's Shadow Minister
um asking him the business secretary of
course Jonathan Reynolds asking him uh
how labor if they were in power would
resolve the continuing strikes not only
by the ambulance service but other NHS
unions as well that coming up in just a
few moments time to stay tuned
[Music]